all right so we've talked about git and
github we've talked about how to use
github and how to introduce changes to
projects but we haven't really talked
about how you would actually work on
those projects on your own computer in
your own text editor or IDE to do that
you need to clone the repository now
we've talked about branching we've
talked about forking so those are kind
of ways of making copies of of code when
you clone you're also making a copy of
the code but first let's talk about what
working locally means when you're
working on github.com
you're working totally on what's called
the remote repository but part of what's
cool about it is that it's distributed
which means you can have a copy of the
entire project on your own computer with
no network connection and continue your
work but to do that you have to work
locally on your own machine when you
clone you can do it easily from github
com either in an IDE in github desktop
app or using the terminal that brings
down a copy to your local computer you
can still communicate with the remote
repository that will still be stored on
github.com you'll have to think these
changes manually they don't happen
automatically and also you should know
that your co-workers your colleagues are
also communicating with the remote
repository so when you push up changes
from your local copy of the repository
when you push those up to github someone
else can pull those changes to their own
local environment and see your changes
or continue work so just to recap when
you want to bring a repository down and
work on it in your own development
environment you'll clone the repository